I saw Kylie Jenner become a billionaire
when she was 20 and I was 27 I was like
she is way richer than I am and so it
means that she's doing something
different than I am by an order of
magnitude that I don't understand and
she had a personal brand but I was like
you know what Chris jener has been
building her brand since she was five
like okay I'll write that off as a fluke
but then honor McGregor had proper 12
George Clooney had casamigos The Rock
has terana multibillion doll things like
seemingly overnight I was like I'm
playing this wrong I still wasn't
convinced because I didn't want to be
famous and I was sat across the table
from a friend of mine who's famous you
would recognize him and I said like
don't you get bothered by having like
weirdo shove at your house like three
times a week and he said if that's the
price I have to pay for the impact I
want to have I'd pay that price twice a
day and seven days a week